best comic-book adaptation to film
hands-down no argument
see you later girls all right I know I'm
in the minority here but I don't really
like the Christopher Nolan Batman movies
I don't I really just feel like they're
overrated okay well that's um that's
just an opinion
you see that's why I prefaced it by
saying I know I'm in the minority oh you
know what no no not really it's not
awkward at least not until you said
awkward now it's awkward because of what
you said anyway anyway what
anyway what really says because when you
say anyway then you have to follow it up
with an actual contribution to the
conversation we're having yeah no look
at me look at me look at me look at me
look at me there's no yikes
and the reason why there's no yikes is
this there's nothing scary about this
situation okay it's a very low stakes
situation
oh no not all right and come here no
don't look at him don't look it either
those guys look at me all right all
right
what cuz after you say all right you
have to follow that up with something
don't do it don't look at them do not
look at them no no do not look at them
do not look at them don't tell us how
you really feel you know what I'll tell
you how I really feel
listen I really feel like you're an
[ __ ] who has nothing interesting to
say it's what right here
tell me an opinion that you have about
something just one opinion that you have
about anything at all just an opinion
anything sure an opinion share an
opinion share an opinion share an
opinion right now just all the top of
your head share an opinion anything just
one opinion that's all I'm asking share
one opinion right now
I just like everything that everyone
else likes in pop culture
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't know you mean
[Music]
okay
you